un séparateur régulateur de température
accessoires de tuyauterie spire axe
sarko propose des outils qui permet
d'utiliser la vapeur comme produits
énergétiques pour être proche de paris
et assurer son développement
cette entreprise britannique est venu
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
en 1977
aujourd'hui les effets du bric sites
sont anticipés à la fois un sur le taux
de change qui effectivement peut jouer
beaucoup de par nos achats qui sont
quand même important d'angleterre et
deux sur les droits de douane et les
droits tout simplement d'accès au marché
européen
aujourd'hui les conséquences sont très
limitées demain nous verrons si
effectivement il y en avait des plus
importantes des conséquences connues
dans deux ans après les négociations
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni nous attendons effectivement michel
vergnier qu'il négocie au mieux les
intérêts européens dans le cadre de cet
essai d'accord à savoir notamment un
libre échange ou un quasi libre échange
effectivement des biens entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni afin de
limiter l'impact potentiel de ce pack
site sur l'activité d'une entreprise
française à travers son implantation
mondiale les risques immédiats pour le
groupe seraient limitées je pense que l'
influence de ce break site sur la vie de
la société française spie rail sarko
aura peu d'influencé du côté de
l'atelier plusieurs produits achetés
dans les filiales installées dans tous
les continents notamment au royaume uni
avec la chute du cours de la livre
depuis le vote du bric site en juin 2016
la filiale française bénéficie d'une
diminution des coûts aujourd'hui le taux
de change est favorable à la france et
donc nous achetons nos produits avec un
prix plus compétitif
vu la diversité de nos produits le
nombre d' usine que l'on a dans le monde
je ne suis pas inquiet l'entreprise peut
continuer à exporter sans se préoccuper
pour l'instant du changement des tarifs
douaniers dans l'attenté des résultats
des négociations